you or someone you care about
may have been diagnosed with prostate
cancer
this video will help you understand some
of the main treatment options available
prostate cancer is a type of cancer that
forms in a man's prostate gland
most prostate tumors grow slowly
compared to other types of cancer
you and your doctor will decide your
treatment based on several factors
these factors include the grade and
stage of your cancer
your health and medical history
and your age
there may be other factors that are
important to you and your family
the treatments for prostate cancer may
include active surveillance
prostatectomy surgery radiation therapy
hormone therapy and immunotherapy
active surveillance means frequent
doctor visits to closely monitor any
growth or changes in your prostate
during these visits your doctor will
feel your prostate by inserting a gloved
finger into your rectum
this is called a digital rectal exam
in addition a blood test will be done to
check the level of a substance in your
blood
called psa men with prostate cancer
often have a higher psa blood level
sometimes active surveillance means your
doctor will take a biopsy of your
prostate
during a biopsy your doctor will remove
prostate tissue samples
through the rectum with a needle
you may need to have surgery called
prostatectomy
to remove your prostate gland
another treatment called radiation
therapy uses radiation to shrink tumors
and kill cancer cells
in external beam radiation a machine
aims radiation from outside your body to
the prostate
in contrast internal radiation uses
pieces of radioactive material
placed within the tumor
hormone therapy is another treatment for
prostate cancer
it affects certain substances made by
your body called hormones
prostate cancer needs these hormones to
grow
hormone therapy drugs can prevent cancer
growth in two ways
first the drugs can block the action of
the one or more hormones on your
prostate
second the drugs can block or reduce the
amount of hormones made by your body
immuno-oncology also known as
immunotherapy
helps your immune system fight cancer
for example
one treatment uses certain immune cells
taken from your body
these cells are grown in the lab and
given a vaccine that makes them more
active
then the activated immune cells are
returned to your body to help attack
cancer cells
your doctor may prescribe other
treatments than the ones described here
talk to your doctor if you have
questions about your prescribed
medication
or have any side effects
be sure to take your medications as
directed by your doctor